hello how are you nice to see you
finally okay this is a first for me
entering a domestic competition actually
today I'm going to show you how to cook
chicken with sis missing
chicken with sesame seed yes and who
taught you this dish I just learned it
from my mother my granny I I always do
my cooking at home because I told he
doesn't like to cook at home he is
better in his restaurant he's like me
why I haven't got the staff at home get
that nice no mustard oil oh yes it's
nice yeah
we never use refine our but we prefer is
the master died right and that's the
flavor yeah
we do for less on I feel like I'm back
at school with my home economics gotcha
yeah yeah young and sexy onions garlic
in chibis she put it home yeah yeah
Oh chicken in it's quite dry but very
slim and beautiful
oh boy from a yoga
[Music]
the color has to remain green so it's a
green curry Jesus this is a house white
competition you're so serious and so
strict they will remain green yeah
promise yeah that smells delicious
mm-hmm kind of looks amazing yes
[Music]
okay good very tempting isn't it is very
tempting
it looks fantastic yeah
are you hungry I am a little bit I don't
like to eat before I go into
competitions nervous energy yes yes Tina
since you are nervous you don't want to
eat so I have a little taste
yes very good everything is perfect
yeah everything I'm not gonna say
darling I will say chef thank you thank
you thank you most of that delicious
fingers crossed so this is a token of
love for me and just you're going to
bring it it's a good luck okay
Cheetos particular change it kinda pie
sesame seed paste at the end at the end